JOINED BY GUENTZEL.
CROSBY, LOOKIN ON THE PENGUINS.
CROSBY, ON. THE FACE-
OFF CIRCLE THIS YEAR.
MIDDLE OF THE ICE.
MARINO, WHEN HE STEPS UP TO THE
CENTERLINEIT CREATEA 2 .
NOTHING IS REALLY WORKING FOR
THE PENGUINS RIGHT NOW.
>> Steve: TRYING TO COUNTER , A
ABLE TO SPIN OFF.
PETTERSEN FINDHIM FOR THE
SCORES! , 500!,
CHANCES THAT WERE PASSED UP,
ESPECIAL EAIN THAT PERIOD
IT WE'LL SEE IF IT'S TIGHTER
ARE NOT IN THE SECOND. RST AND
IN THE SECOND.
A GOES OFF THE SIDE OF THE NET
RIGHT TO THE TOP OF  TO LETANG.
HE DANCE HERE THE OFFENSE
SEEMS TO KNOW WHERE THE PUCKBRI
HE GOT CLOSED OFF. HARD SHSH
A CHANCE FOR VAN RIEMSDYK, AND
THAT IS OFF THE BODY AND ,  WIT
TOO MANY CHANCES FROM ALL
DIFF
>> Steve: ALMOST ONE OF THOSE T
TRYING TO MAKE IT A ONE GOAL
CHANCE.
FRONT
WE'V'VIN
THE MIDDLE OF THE SCREEN.
NOBODY PICKAND.
NOBODY WITH A HEAD ON A SWIVEL,
>> Bob: IT DID NOT LOOK GOOD AT
ALL.
HE WAS IN A LOT OF GIROUX  TO P?
IT'S LETAN AGAIN